bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition d'en quête d'europe nous sommes
à l'hôtel de coulanges dans le marais à
la maison de l'europe pour cette
nouvelle édition
dans cette émission retour sur les bancs
de l'école en allemagne où les rythmes
scolaires font aussi débat
ensuite direction l'irlande un des seuls
pays d'europe qui n'autorise pas
l'avortement
enfin direction l'albanie ou des
associations tentent de juguler la
traite des êtres humains
mais d'abord sandra cerqueira nous
emmène en l'espagne où l'indépendance
n'est pas juste une idéologie sandra on
assiste à une espèce de fièvre
indépendantiste en europe depuis le
début de la crise
est ce que c'est vraiment le cas oui on
le voit en fait il ya une crainte au
sein l'union européenne de se voir se
fragmenter un certain nombre d'états
membres
et c'est vrai que la crise agit comme un
catalyseur parce que les revendications
indépendantistes ont toujours existé au
sein l'union européenne mais le
phénomène s'amplifie avec la crise donc
c'est le cas notamment en belgique le
principal dirigeant indépendantiste bart
de wever qui réclame aux francophones
d'aller vers une voie plus
confédéraliste on voit aussi en écosse
que l'argument économique est très
important alors eux ils ont négocié un
accord avec londres pour organiser un
référendum en 2014 en catalogne aussi
aimerait organiser un référendum là où
nous avons
alizée le reportage sauf que madrid là
pour le coup n'est pas d'accord majorité
de catalans seraient prêts à voter oui à
ce référendum se demander leur
indépendance
donc on vous suit en espagne le sujet
est partout il envahit les conversations
les journaux pour les catalans devenir
indépendant vire à l'obsession
nous sommes à vic près de barcelone
ici tous sont persuadés que sans
l'espagne la catalogne serait plus riche
et livré mieux cela fait trop d'années
que l'état espagnol nous étouffe la
catalogne paye chaque année à madrid 16
milliards d'euros et en contrepartie on
ne reçoit quasiment rien en aide ou en
investissement pour la santé ou
l'éducation
on paye trois fois plus que le reste de
l'espagne on n'en peut plus de payer
autant et de recevoir c'est peu avec la
crise les gens ouvrent enfin les yeux on
se rend compte d injustice d'autant que
nous aussi on a subi des coupes
budgétaires aux fenêtres et aux balcons
la bannière indépendantiste frappé d'une
étoile blanche et fièrement accrochée et
même au fronton de la mairie le drapeau
espagnol a disparu ici ce n'est pas
l'espagne
ici c'est la catalogne on a été conquis
par l'espagne mais on n'est pas espagnol
on est catalan nous sommes une nation
qui a son identité sa langue sa culture
nous sommes à notre pays un pays qui n'a
pas d'état en 2009 le village s'est
déclarée état catalan libre suite à un
référendum populaire
un vote pour l'indépendance qui a eu
lieu dans plus de 600 villes de
catalogne et à chaque fois une majorité
écrasante de huy pour s'affranchir de
l'espagne bien que symbolique cette
déclaration de souveraineté a empiré les
relations avec madrid
c'est à ce moment là que le mouvement
indépendantiste s'est intensifiée en
catalogne
madrid a très mal réagi ils ont voulu
interdire ce référendum populaire en
ayant recours à la justice
l'espagne affirme ex était
inconstitutionnelle parce que nous
n'étions pas une vraie nation et ça a
été très mal vécue par les catalans et
pour ne pas relâcher la pression
le village a décidé depuis peu deux
lui verser ses impôts locaux à l'état
central ils sont récoltés directement
par la catalogne
une façon de répondre à madrid qui a
toujours refusé à la région catalane
l'autonomie budgétaire tant réclamée
c'est un acte de protestation et par la
même occasion nous préparons l'avenir
est notre indépendance c'est une sorte
d' exercice grandeur nature pour
apprendre à administrer nous même nos
impôts nous savons que nous ne pouvons
attendre aucune aide des espagnols car
ce qu'ils aimeraient sait garder notre
argent
le processus d'indépendance se
concrétise à barcelone compose déjà les
bases pour la création d'un état
depuis un mois le conseil de transition
nationale travaille en toute discrétion
douze membres des politiques des
universitaires ébauche les contours d'un
fisc d'une sécurité sociale d'une banque
centrale catalane et d'un pouvoir
judiciaire
une feuille de route chargée en
attendant le référendum pour
l'indépendance prévue en 2014 par le
gouvernement catalan ça n'a rien à voir
avec le fait de vouloir des frontières
ou de se replier sur nous-mêmes
au contraire c'est la possibilité et
d'enfin faire entendre notre voix à
l'europe et à l'international et de ne
plus dépendre de l'espagne pour décider
de nos politiques d'enfin parler d'égal
à égal avec madrid
le rapport de force avec madrid ne fait
que se durcir en réponse le gouvernement
espagnol continue d'affirmer que ce
référendum n'a aucune valeur juridique
il est clair que la constitution
espagnole ne reconnaît pas le statut
d'auto détermination pour l'instant on
va vers une rupture avec l'état central
mais nous sommes déterminés à demander
l'aide des tribunaux internationaux pour
faire reconnaître notre indépendance
on ne peut pas bafouer cette volonté
démocratique
solution pour les uns catastrophe pour
les autres l'indépendance fait peur aux
industriels catalan certains ont déjà
menacé de déplacer leurs sièges de
barcelone si le scénario
indépendantistes se confirme c'est la
région la plus dynamique du pays et les
exportations augmentent pour cet
économiste
ce n'est pas le moment de courir le
risque de perdre de l'activité pierre de
réduire le pib
le risque en devenant indépendant c'est
que nous quittions l'europe nous
n'aurions alors plus l'appui de la
banque centrale européenne être en
dehors de l'union européenne revient à
payer des taxes et 60 % de nos
exportations sont à destination de
l'europe
ce serait un surcoût considérable qui
plomberait notre économie
sans compter que les entreprises
catalanes ne sont pas à l'abri d'un
boycott de l'espagne
plus qu'un boycott l'espagne pourrait si
la catalogne quitte l'union européenne
bloquer le processus d'adhésion
car il faut l'unanimité de tous les pays
membres le chemin vers l'indépendance
pourrait être encore long
sandra le voit bien dans votre reportage
il ya vraiment cette idée ancrée chez
les catalans qu'il s'en sortirait
finalement bien mieux sans l'espagne oui
pour les indépendantistes catalans
l'indépendance c'est la seule solution
ce ils en ont assez en fait de payer
plus que de raison ils mettent en avant
leurs atouts économiques ils ont un pib
important ils ont un tourisme aussi très
florissant des exportations qui augmente
mais malgré cette bonne santé économique
ils ont un déficit très important et
donc ils se disent que s'ils payaient
moins à l'état central
il aurait de quoi réduire leurs déficits
temps il y a des gens que cela effraie
oui il ya pour beaucoup en fait
l'indépendance n'est pas économiquement
viable certains économistes et certains
chefs d'entreprise disent que si l'état
catalan devient indépendant le pib
pourrait chuter de 25% et ce serait un
état indépendant avec plusieurs
milliards de déficit donc c'est
inenvisageable et surtout s'ils
demandent leur indépendance
il pourrait être amené à sortir donc de
l'europe et liliane reedy en fait la
vice-présidente de la commission
européenne
william reading a laissé entendre que
tout pays qui demandait son indépendance
serait amené certainement à renégocier
donc son adhésion
or il faut l'unanimité de tous les états
membres pour donc obtenir cette adhésion
et madrid continue à s'opposer donc ils
se disent que le processus pourrait ne
jamais aboutir ça pourrait être trop de
risques pour finalement un résultat trop
incertain merci sandra si on parle de
modèles allemands en terme de
compétitivité et c'est aussi le cas sur
les rythmes scolaires longtemps vanté
comme un modèle pourtant outre-rhin le
débat fait rage
et c'est pas le bouffard qui nous en
parle
bonne la question des rythmes scolaires
a largement fait débat en france ces
derniers mois et on a souvent pris le
cas allemand comme modèle oui on est
allé voir en allemagne comment
fonctionne le système scolaire le rythme
scolaire alors en allemagne outre-rhin
ce système est de la compétence des
länder donc des régions ce système est
un mutant 11h30 13h30 le matin à peu
près l'après midi est libre alors il
coûte moins cher aux finances publiques
et il est plus respectueux du rythme
physiologique des enfants 208 jours de
classe par an soit 64 de plus qu'en
france on a misé sur l'intégration et
l'apprentissage par l'école mais aussi
par les activités extrascolaires donc là
on vous suit en bavière où vous avez été
accompagné par mélanie montant très tôt
le matin
c'est un ballet d'écoliers qui
s'activent en bavière
comme dans le reste du pays début de
journée à 7h40 pour les petits allemands
michael kraus est instituteur dans le
village de castle ici comme le veut la
tradition allemande
la classe est donné le matin ils
débutent leur journée avec des petits
jeux d'informatique
alors ici on commence le matin où
commence le matin à 7h40 les cours
durent environ 45 minutes
il y a deux pauses une première de 20
minutes à 9h10 puis une seconde un peu
plus tard les cours finissent
normalement aux alentours de 12h40
c'est ce système qui est aujourd'hui la
source d'inspiration du gouvernement
français dans sa réforme des rythmes
scolaires en allemagne
les élèves ont en moyenne 193 jours
d'école par an contre 140 en france
moins de vacances mais un rythme plus ou
avec moins d'heures de classe seulement
cinq par jour
au final c'est moins de fatigue pour les
écoliers ouais je pense que bien sûr
quand on doit rester à l'école jusqu'à
midi et qu'ensuite on retourne dans son
environnement familial on est peut-être
moins fatiguer le si on reste à l'école
jusqu'à 16 heures à l'école on ne peut
jamais vraiment se décontracter à castle
et dans la plupart des écoles
d'allemagne on compte en moyenne 21
élèves par classe loukas 9 ans est en
dernière année de primaire
d'abord on allemand ensuite cours de
maths mois après l'école je rentre à la
maison aujourd'hui j'ai match de foot
l'après-midi préfère être dehors et joue
avec mes amis autres classes ici ses
cours d'orthographe avec reina strauss
institutrice depuis 17 ans à cas cela en
tant que professeur l'après midi je peux
travailler corriger et préparer mes
cours pour les prochains jours à 13
heures les jeunes allemands filt à la
garderie d'autres vont en cours de
musique ou encore aux sports autre
différence de taille avec la france le
salaire des professeurs ici à munich en
bavière un jeune instituteur commence
avec 2200 euros net par mois
1600 points français le système éducatif
financé par les länder régions
politiques qui ont le statut
anticipation à l'échelle nationale pour
y préférer marley et de l'industrie nos
services
comme tous les matins accès le brûlage
prépare les enfants
une nouvelle journée d'école pour shirin
et noam le papa est français il vit en
allemagne depuis 15 ans ces enfants sont
nés et scolarisés ici à munich alors il
peut comparer ça leur laisse beaucoup de
temps beaucoup plus de temps pour faire
leurs devoirs ou pour ou pour simplement
aller à la bibliothèque ou pour ce pur
pour en fait pour avoir la possibilité
d'apprendre par d'autres moyens
simplement que par l'école la question
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait des enfants
l'après-midi effectivement quand les
enfants n'ont pas d'école il faut les
occuper comme on travaille tous les deux
avec ma femme on arrive assez on a
réussi on a eu de la chance on a réussi
à avoir une place pour les deux mais il
ya beaucoup de gens effectivement qu'ils
sont obligés finalement de travailler en
mi temps de ne pas travailler de ne pas
travailler pour pouvoir s'occuper de
leurs enfants d'après midi en allemagne
la tradition est tenace et
particulièrement dans les länder de
l'ancienne allemagne de l'est où la
maman reste à la maison pour élever ses
enfants dans plus de 50 % des couples
avec un enfant de moins de 6 ans seul
l'homme travaille donc pas facile de
gérer un emploi du temps avec ce rythme
scolaire
il n'ya justement beaucoup de jeunes
gens qui demandent des places en
garderies etc à pain pour l'instant y'a
pas les infrastructures pour un modèle
jalousé par toute l'europe qui se remet
aujourd'hui en question le système
s'essouffle devant les inégalités
sociales
du coup pourquoi pas une école à temps
plein c'est nécessaire pour deux raisons
tout d'abord c'est une possibilité
pédagogique
on dispose de plus en plus de temps pour
l'enseignement d'un autre côté il ya
tout simplement la réalité sociale et
plus en plus de familles ont besoin de
cette possibilité de laisser leurs
enfants à l'école toute la journée le
nombre de femmes actives augmente de
plus en plus et je pense que c'est une
question d'emploi du temps la journée
complète à l'école est une conséquence
du développement du travail des femmes
aujourd'hui les pédagogues allemands
restent satisfaits mais pour continuer à
garantir à la fois une bonne éducation
et l'emploi des femmes
l'allemagne doit remettre en cause ses
vieilles traditions depuis 2004 plus de
4 milliards d'euros ont été investis
pour permettre à un tiers des écoles
primaires d'offrir une journée de classe
à temps plein
walt ce qui est étonnant dans votre
reportage c'est qu'en france on prend
l'allemagne comme modèle pour les
rythmes scolaires et eux mêmes sont en
train de remettre en question leur
propre rythme scolaire
alors oui c'est paradoxal nous on leur
jalouse leur après midi libre et eux
nous envient leur notre école à la
journée à temps plein le système
allemand est en pleine remise en cause
comme le confiait axel le jeune papa
dans le reportage
les familles ont du mal à occuper leurs
enfants les après-midis cela coûte cher
alors il ya bien les kinder garden les
garderies les cours de piano les cours
de danse tout ça mais ça coûte très cher
et de plus en plus de familles laissent
leurs enfants devant la télévision à la
maison et tout ceci paul a une incidence
sur l'emploi des femmes bien entendu il
y avait une tradition en allemagne la
maman qui s'arrêtent de travailler pour
s'occuper de sa progéniture
toute la journée et notamment les
après-midis désormais crise oblige les
choses changent en fait l'emploi des
femmes grimpe en allemagne et le nombre
de familles monoparentales avec une mère
seule augmente les mamans sont obligés
de travailler ce qui pourrait bien
pousser les autorités allemandes a
changé et a basculé vers une école à
temps plein merci paul on croit souvent
que le droit à l'avortement est garanti
sur tout le territoire de l'union
européenne pourtant en irlande
l'interruption de grossesse qui est
toujours totalement interdite et un
sordide fait divers a de nouveau relancé
les débats
flora sauvage s'y est rendu
flora depuis plusieurs mois le débat sur
l'avortement s'est réinvitée sous les
feux de l'actualité pour quelle raison
il ya eu un fait divers avec la mort
d'une jeune femme d'origine indienne qui
vivait à le gaulois en irlande en
octobre 2012 cette jeune femme était
enceinte de quelques semaines
un soir elle se présente aux urgences
est-ce qu'elle avait des maux de ventre
et on lui dit qu'elle est en train de
faire une fausse couche
sauf que la fausse couche tard d'en
avoir lieu elle demande un avortement et
le médecin lui dit écoutez le coeur de
votre foetus bas encore ici en irlande
l'avortement est totalement interdit je
ne peux rien faire
elle perd le bébé et une semaine plus
tard elle meurt d'une septicémie fait
divers tragique une femme enceinte de 31
ans meurt après avoir demandé un
avortement qui lui a été refusée automne
2012 après le décès de sa vita à la pana
var le débat sur l'avortement est
relancée en irlande ce fait divers
dramatique suscite un tollé général dans
le pays où lee vg reste interdite
après 5 référendum ce n'est pas la
première fois que la question revient
sur le devant de la scène
niall birane dirige le planning familial
ici on milite en faveur de la levée de
l'interdiction de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse
maintenant en 1983 un un moment dans la
constitution introduit l'idée que la vie
de la mère et celle de son bébé ont la
même valeur
depuis il n'y a pas une loi pour
préciser ce que cela signifie réellement
il a fallu un drame en 1992 pour
remettre en question cet amendement une
adolescente de 14 ans tombée enceinte
après un viol à qui on avait refusé un
avortement a conduit la cour suprême à
se prononcer on a eu une interprétation
de la cour suprême en 1992 qui dit que
si la vie de la mère est en danger
un avortement est envisageable mais la
difficulté c'est qu'aucune législation
n'a été mise en place aucune consigne
n'a été donnée au corps médical
si bien qu'aujourd'hui encore recourir à
une ivg m passible de la réclusion à
perpétuité
chaque année 5000 irlandaises vont à
l'étranger pour se faire avorter
en trente ans près de 150000
on fait le voyage car en irlande le
poids de l'église a toujours empêché les
évolutions en la matière les catholiques
restent farouchement opposés à
l'avortement allemand à je donne la vie
et personne n'a le pouvoir d' ôter la
vie à part du sud j'aspire donc je ne
pense pas qu'on ait la liberté d'avorter
n'ont subi un enfant je suis fatigué
d'entendre ce qui se sont accrus les
libéraux ils ont ce perdu la foi dans de
très très très très très rares cas
d'accord mais en dehors de ça non en
2010 la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme a condamné l'irlande à cause du
flou juridique qui entoure l'avortement
sous la pression internationale le
gouvernement s'est engagé à déposer un
projet de loi avant l'été une décision
saluée par sept députés de gauche
elle milite en faveur de la
libéralisation de l'avortement
le gouvernement a traîné des pieds
depuis des années sur cette question
c'est tout à fait historique même si ça
ne concerne qu'un petit nombre de femmes
symboliquement c'est très important car
ça veut dire que pour la première fois
en irlande
nous allons avoir une loi sur
l'avortement et c'est pour cette raison
que les opposants sont si énervé qu'il
manifeste tant est qu'il met autant
d'argent pour des campagnes de publicité
financée par les états unis
car en irlande les lobbys pro vie sont
très influents pour les opposants à
l'avortement le foetus est un être
humain dès les premiers instants de la
vie
evelyne travail au sein de l'association
pro life campaign elle a participé aux
manifestations anti avortement de ces
derniers mois la raison pour laquelle
l'avortement est une question qui pose
problème c'est qu'il y a deux vies en
jeu il y a deux corps ce n'est pas que
ma vie qui est en jeu c'est aussi l'avis
de mon bébé donc les deux doivent être
protégés
et cette vision est relayée au parlement
par le sénateur mélanie l'opposition à
l'avortement en irlande est souvent
présentée comme une question
exclusivement religieuse dans une
société plurielle
on ne peut pas légiférer à partir de la
foi de certains mais c'est une mauvaise
compréhension de notre position la façon
dont je vois les choses que oui bien sûr
on est inspiré par la foi mais cela
relève du bon sens
un instinct naturel de protection des
droits de l'homme mais les mentalités
évoluent la jeunesse est plus ouverte
sur la question même si l'avortement
sans motif apparent n'est pas encore à
l'ordre du jour je pense que ça devrait
être légalisé
car c'est le corps de la femme la
décision doit lui appartenir
et de toute façon dans quelques années
je pense que ça sera légal
alors pourquoi pas maintenant je ne suis
pas d'accord avec elle car il s'agit
d'une vie à l'intérieur de soi
je dis ça maintenant mais si jamais je
tomber enceinte dans six mois je serai
peut-être la première allait apporter
alors je ne sais pas malgré le déclin de
l'influencé de l'église catholique en
irlande les esprits évoluent lentement
d'après un sondage 85% des irlandais
sont favorables à l'avortement si la vie
de la mère est en danger
seuls 36% des personnes interrogées se
prononcent pour la légalisation de l'ibg
quelles que soient les réseaux flora
quelle est la législation en matière
d'avortement en irlande alors l'irlande
est le dernier pays avec malte en europe
à considérer l'avortement comme illégal
donc en irlande quand on pratiquer un
avortement on est passible de la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
c'est totalement illégal mais que
pourrait changer cette nouvelle loi sur
l'avortement en fait pas grand chose
puisque c'est un assouplissement très
timide 2
la législation en vigueur ce projet de
loi a pour but de permettre l'avortement
en cas de danger pour la vie de la mère
mais l'avortement restera interdite en
cas de viol en cas d'inceste ou en cas
d'anomalie du foetus donc les
irlandaises ont continué à aller en
angleterre pour pratiquer un avortement
dans ces cas là où en cas de choix
personnel de tout à fait pas avoir
d'enfant est ce que tout cela est de la
faute de l'église parce qu'on voit bien
dans votre reportage que le poids de
l'église est important en irlande
oui on sent que le poids de l'église est
encore très important l'église
catholique a est totalement opposé à
l'interruption de grossesse après on
sent que la jeunesse irlandaise est plus
favorable à l'avortement
c'est vrai contre discute avec des
jeunes néerlandais rond sans qu'ils sont
toutes plus tournés vers l'étranger
il voit qu'à l'étranger ça se pratique
et ils sont plutôt favorables quand même
à l'idée d'assouplir la législation en
vigueur
merci flora si l'albanie ne fait pas
partie de l'union européenne ce petit
pays bénéficient de fonds européens
notamment pour juguler la traite des
êtres humains
fabrice qu'une elle s'est rendue à tira
la capitale du pays
fabrice pourquoi ce choix d'aller en
albanie alors que le pays ne fait pas
partie de l'union européenne en albanie
ne fait pas partie de l'union européenne
mais l'albanie est clairement sous
surveillance de l'union pour sur cette
question des trafics qu'il soit que ce
soit des trafics d'armes soient les
trafics de drogue ou comme pour notre
sujet les trafics d'êtres humains ces
réseaux dits albanais sont très
implantés en belgique en allemagne dans
les pays scandinaves et sur le problème
spécifique du trafic des êtres humains
c'est la grèce et l'italie qui sont
particulièrement exposés du coup on est
vraiment face à un problème à dimension
européenne
et l'idée avec le reportage c'était
d'aller se rendre compte sur place à
tirana comment travaillent ces ong qui
lutte contre ce trafic des êtres humains
comment ils travaillent au quotidien
porté à bout de bras par des
financements européens
levine chemin gauche chi kung fu
mitchell qu ils ne mangeraient pour nous
schulz aixois licha c'est la dernière
campagne d'une ong albanaise contre la
traite des êtres humains le dernier
symbole de la mobilisation contre ces
trafics qui sont trafiqués mais
stationnaire
en albanie l'exploitation des enfants ou
la prostitution ont longtemps été des
sujets tabous ya un problème récurrent
dans un pays où le salaire moyen ne
dépasse pas 200 euros par mois
depuis quelques années les choses
changent et la lutte contre ces trafics
s'organise depuis son petit bureau de la
capitale tirana
daniela coordonne l'action des ong
dédiée à l'enfance un vaste réseau
d'alerté dead à la réinsertion parti
d'un constat
ici il n'y a pas de service public qui
aide les enfants difficultés à se
réinsérer
c'est à nous à alger d'assurer cette
mission il faut réintégrer ces jeunes
victimes de violences de trafic ou de
travaux forcés et comme l'état ne le
fait pas notre travail est très
important dans leur travail au quotidien
les ong mettent l'accent sur la
prévention exemple dans cet immeuble au
coeur d'un quartier très défavorisé de
tirana un accueil de jour pour des
enfants en grande précarité et un
soutien pour leurs familles les enfants
qu'à l'être on a appris aujourd'hui
chaque jour une cinquantaine d'enfants
déscolarisés se retrouvent autour de ces
tables pour des cours ou des activités
une alternative à la rue ce sont pour la
plupart des enfants livrés à eux mêmes
et qui vivent dans une grande pauvreté
ils sont tous des victimes potentielles
de n'importe quel trafic ou souvent
utilisés par leurs familles pour gagner
de l'argent
il s'appelle beyram berti ou franco ils
ont entre 4 et 15 ans tous racontent la
même histoire les mêmes difficultés
familiales et travaille et fait partie
de leur quotidien
moi je vends des noises aux gens et
après je donne l'argent à maman quand on
rentre à la maison
moi quand je suis dehors je cherche du
fer où je vais sur internet et le faire
que je trouve
je le vends pour ma famille eux sont
restés à tirana mais parfois les enfants
seraient loués ou envoyés au kosovo en
macédoine ou en grèce pour travailler
quelqu'un a vu la maîtresse ouanna pour
sony la masse ati certains réseaux
criminels cible les familles pauvres et
profite de ce trafic
après plusieurs années à la direction de
ce centre d'accueil
elle voit la situation s'améliorait
lentement je pense qu'il reste beaucoup
de difficultés il y à certaines
problématiques que l'on n'arrive
toujours pas à résoudre à cause de la
bureaucratie
même s'il est à adopter des lois
récemment le chemin est encore long pour
que l'on réussisse ensemble à trouver
des réponses aux problèmes de ses
enfants et de leurs familles
sous la pression de l'union européenne
l'albanie a en effet adopté une série de
lois mises en place des plans d'actions
depuis une dizaine d'années pour lutter
contre le trafic d'êtres humains
l'homme clé du dispositif le vice
ministre de l'intérieur
face aux critiques ne redonne d'oka
réclame du temps la coopération avec les
ong c'est vrai et à améliorer pour
réinsérer les victimes dans la société
il faut aussi que l'on perfectionne
notre cadre juridique
même si le cadre existant me semble déjà
efficace doit travailler à l'adapter aux
standards européens et ses carences sont
encore plus criantes en matière de
prostitution
c'est du moins le constat fait par les
ong comme celle d'ariel à mitry les
femmes sont victimes de stigmatisation
par la société albanaise et les
structures de réintégration manque
seulement 5 sur l'ensemble du territoire
pour des raisons de sécurité impossible
de filmer ses centres d'accueil pour
fait leur intégration a débuté mais sans
lui besoin d'une maison d'une place pour
dominer la sécurité pour la nourriture
et après construit un projet de
l'intégration et si toujours c'est
difficile trouver une place que ce soit
pour les enfants ou pour les femmes
victimes de trafic
la solution passe par l'éducation
l'europe soutient certains programmes de
sensibilisation à tirana comme dans le
reste de l'albanie mais dans un pays où
l'on manque de tout les trafiquants ont
encore une longueur d'avancé
fabrice on voit bien dans votre
reportage l'empreinte de ses mafia
albanaise qui sont elles finalement
alors d'abord on parle pas de mafia on
parle de clans deux clans d'une dizaine
quinzaine d'individus implantés un peu
partout en europe qui gère ces réseaux
réseaux de trafic de drogue trafic
d'armes trafic d'êtres humains
évidemment pour donner un chiffre on
estime à 30 milles prostituée d'origine
albanaise qui travaillerait en europe
ces clans donc des petits clans très
influent en albanie gravitent autour du
pouvoir autour des candidats dans les
différentes élections
et ça c'est un vrai problème pour les
ong ce problème de corruption et
d'influencés très marquée de ses petits
que l'on albanais dans un pays qui est
jeune démocratiquement ils apprennent la
démocratie et ses traits du coup c'est
un processus qui est lent le pouvoir ne
nie pas ce problème de corruption mais
il est évidemment très très présent
fabrice et associations luttent un petit
peu comme elles peuvent contre ces
phénomènes
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait les
juguler finalement il ya plusieurs
choses à faire d'abord c'est sur le
statut des victimes
il ya un vrai effort à faire de ce côté
là une prostituée qui voudraient se
réinsérer pour elle c'est quasiment
impossible aujourd'hui des structures de
réinsertion sont très rares et puis et
surtout elles sont stigmatisées montré
du doigt c'est très compliqué de
reprendre une vie normale
pour ces pour ses victimes et puis il ya
surtout à mon avis le problème central
que ce soit pour la prostitution ou pour
le travail forcé c'est la scolarisation
c'est un pays très jeune albanie 40% la
population a moins de 18 ans et sur
cette population seulement eu un enfant
sur deux aura accès à la à l'école
maternelle problème de déscolarisation
problèmes de pauvreté de 100 euros de
salaire moyen un terreau très fertile
pour ses différents trafics et une
tentation pour les familles évidemment
de mettre au travail les enfants plutôt
que de les mettre à l'école est là
dessus l'albanie travail mais le chemin
est évidemment très long merci fabrice
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission à
la maison de l'europe à l'hôtel de
coulanges à paris nous on se retrouve
très vite sur public sénat et tous les
jours sur publicsenat.fr